c'est vrai que c'est toute une époque
cette année sept années 70 c'est
l'arrivée des consoles qu'on appelait
pong qui sont des consoles multi je mets
tous les jeux se ressemblent et
embrouillé avait deux bars et c'est le
tennis le foot le hockey
pour 300 francs environ les prix ont
beaucoup baissé le petit écran se
transforme en terrain de football mon
court de tennis les adversaires se
renvoyant la balle grâce à une commande
manuelle le journaliste est plutôt
bienveillant c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
souffert de du traitement par les médias
du jeu vidéo mais là ya pas encore le
mal du jeu vidéo qu'on a qu'on a subi
gea dans les années 80-90 la mâchoire et
crispé le regard fixe les gestes
saccadés les symptômes sont clairs le
diagnostic sans appel ces enfants sont
atteints d'un mal très contemporain la
passion des jeux vidéo il est il a
essayé d'y fiancée reportage n'avait
jamais vu mais le champ lexical du
journalisme les le mal les symptômes les
plans sur les les yeux le crisper etc
enfin je veux dire on voit déjà dans ce
reportage tout l'écart entre les médias
et finalement le jeu vidéo deux cent
quarante mille consoles vendues l'année
dernière en france après les états unis
l'angleterre et l'allemagne nous sommes
donc atteinte nous aussi par cette
épidémie mais d'autres personnes au
contraire il voit un côté bénéfique pour
les jeunes avec le jeu vidéo ils sont
ils participent et il participe avec
patient et il ya une espèce de
compétition avec soi-même ils veulent se
vaincre même ils veulent gagner ils
veulent réussir et à partir du moment où
un enfant heures réussi évidemment il ya
un dynamisme absolument extraordinaire
qui ce qui existe en lui même un
psychologue est quand même eu déjà d'un
certain âge à cette époque et qui
découvre le jeu vidéo un regard très
bienveillant et comprend que finalement
ça aide les enfants à se dépasser ce
alors à se fixer des objectifs etc et
pourtant les médias eux ne le voit pas
quarante ans plus tard l'image des jeux
vidéo à la télé a bien changé selon
bertrand amar aujourd'hui le traitement
qui est fait du jeu vidéo par les médias
et je le trouve très juste on voit bien
aujourd'hui quand il ya une compétition
qui est organisé les médias viennent
salue la ferveur populaire le talent des
joueurs et cetera donc on a un
traitement qui est bienveillant mais
surtout juste les journalistes non plus
les idées préconçues qu'ils avaient à
l'époque
[Musique]